it's grim news another body has just
been recovered from the rubble of the
condo collapse in florida thank you for
joining us
i'm kirsten joyce and i'm christian
casadas right now the death toll is at
11
but 150 people remain unaccounted for
mark stramin is in surfside florida with
the continuing
search efforts rescue workers created a
bucket brigade as they removed concrete
rubble
the size of basketballs bit by bit we're
going to continue and
work ceaselessly officials in suicide
florida
say five days after the collapse there
is still reason
for hope there are certain areas that we
have not gotten to but we've been able
to place cameras that
seem to have large enough spaces voids
that occupants may still be in there
first responders from israel and mexico
are helping in the search
the team from mexico sedania
international
is using a dog named oreo because of the
weight
she can go in other places that have
more instability that another dog cannot
go
some family members have criticized the
search efforts saying they're going too
slowly
over the weekend relatives were escorted
to the site where they got a firsthand
look
at the safety risks involved they
witnessed a rescuer tumbled 25
feet down the mountain that is a perfect
example of the situation that we're
dealing with
federal investigators are also on the
scene the people of florida want to
understand
how could this happen and then what
could we do
to make sure it doesn't happen again an
assessment done by engineers in 2018
noted that in the garage an abundant
cracking and spalling of various degrees
was observed in the concrete columns
beams and walls
but an attorney for the homeowners
association as well as an engineer who
spoke to cbs news
both said nothing warned of an imminent
catastrophe
mark strassman cbs news surfside florida
the national institute of standards and
technology says its team of six
scientists and engineers will collect
first-hand information
on the collapse that will help determine
if a full investigation will be
conducted
the team will only enter the site once
it is deemed safe
for them to do so